foreign
go to Danny in Houston Texas Danny how
can we help
sure
um so I have
um a it's probably a more personal than
than money
um situation but obviously everything's
interconnected so I
um am having a lot of health issues that
because of where we live
um it's uh I have really bad allergies
that lead to really bad asthma
exacerbations and I'm on and off of
steroids and in and out of ERS and I'm
trying all the therapies pleasure and
um as a as a physician
in a special a specialty
um I am in a unique area
um I absolutely love what I do I love
the people I work with I don't want to
move
um but my husband being a good man wants
me to be healthy yes and
um once what's best for for me and my
health and what we found from what I can
tolerate is the coast
either one would be better
um and you know of course that higher
cost of living
um a higher tax bracket and for whatever
reason
um in my field
uh academic uh positions are not paying
as well and so I'm looking at for if we
were to move taking a 50 pay cut and
it's
it's really hard for me
um to look at that and be like how can I
choose myself
over my family's future
um well let's let's pause it for a
second yeah yeah how how
um what would your household income go
to combined income go from what to what
oh
um okay so it would probably go from six
and sevens to fours five okay so if I'm
hearing you right six to seven hundred
thousand to four to five hundred
thousand mm-hmm okay
um I don't want to minimize in any way
the feelings you're feeling but your
family is not going to be destitute nor
is their future going to be hampered by
by that kind of a drop when you're
making that kind of money after the drop
let's that's assuming that that is going
to be the case and that you can't you
can't increase that but let's just as
just two strangers that you called
George am I right every listener out
there is like I think I could make 500
000 working and we and we know you don't
mean it that way but most people heard
that and they're like I think I could
scrape by on four to five hundred
thousand I'd find a way and so I'm I'm
not in any way criticizing you
um because a cut is a cut I don't care
how much money you're making and they're
still making sacrifices to be yeah that
will hurt but but I wanted to start
there Danny and then I would also tell
you that if I were your husband and your
husband's already stepped up in a big
way I want you to choose you choosing
you over the income choosing you over
your role with the rest of the family
we'd rather have you than not you
yes
yeah and of course those are the exact
same things that are being said I just
I'm like there's no guarantee that I
won't get out there and still have those
same issues
have you been to the coast uh let's say
uh the East Coast have you spent two
weeks there
yeah when we've done different vacations
did it improve when I leave yeah yeah
and it is but I've never lived out there
so who knows what would happen during
certain Seasons or illnesses and what is
it that you do
um I I'm a sub-specialist in uh
pulmonary medicine
so you said you're in the academic side
no it's just that you you are typically
associated with an academic center okay
um to for when you're in that well I
also want to challenge you that there's
it's always going to be a pay cut I mean
I don't know that you've checked every
single role in every area and we don't
know what the next six months hold as
you begin to do more research but I
think it's kind of like you're like uh
it's gonna be less pay it's gonna be
it's gonna be hard I want you to be
optimistic about that I'm gonna get my
health back and as a physician you know
that health is wealth I mean it's
everything
what do you what are you what's holding
you back
I think there's I think you kind of said
it but I think there's I think there's
one thing here that's really holding you
back
well we're just it's we're so close
we'll have the the house paid off we'll
be good we'll owe nothing to nobody okay
um how much do you owe on the house
200. okay and yeah and so here's the
thing again I think that's another false
hurdle
um there's a lot of sand on the East
Coast are you aware of this it kind of
goes all the way I mean you know it's
kind of we got it we got up north it
goes all the way down a lot of states
and your specialty pays very well and I
just believe with all the states that
have Sand and Sea Air that there have
got to be some some places where you can
move uh that the income doesn't drop
that much but even if it does you're
still making really good money you sell
the house you're in you may be able to
pay cash for something somewhere else I
I just think you're coming up a lot of
limitations and I still think it's
deeper than that I I know I'm digging is
it deeper than this I think it's I think
you really like where you live and I
think this is a massive change for you
that even could
totally change your life because of your
health I think you're reluctant to
change and pull up Roots that's what I
think
I I don't think you're wrong we've got
three small kids and it's you know to to
find you know child care and get them
restarted and then you're talking about
probably private schools depending on
the areas that we're looking at so it's
another added expense and it just
changes it changes the whole thing where
it works do you want to be miserable
really comfortable do you want to be
miserable or uncomfortable I mean I have
been for like three years so yeah I've
made it this far they're gonna get their
mom back so let's do that for another 25
30 years now is the easiest time to move
when the kids are little they're not
attached they don't care where they're
at
um I I think this is a I think this is a
do I want to be miserable physically
or do I want to be uncomfortable
emotionally and I think you guys got to
do more research I think you got to
spend more time on this this is a
massive move and I honor what you're
feeling that's what I thought was going
on this you know what this is this is
actually not about paying the house off
this is about the massive amount of
change that this move is going to
require and that everybody understands
yeah
I'm just a very very regimented
everything scheduled everything's been
done out and it just feels like it's a
huge mentioned it is Danny because you
know what I bet you your husband's not
am I right he is not I knew it not I
knew it because I would be like yeah
let's move let's go I love change I
really do I think change is great change
is exciting but you pretty much have two
types of people in the world Freaks Like
Me and then normal people like George
thank you with a slight bit of neurosis
you know but the point is is that now
that you've identified what's going on
here's why I was digging
I love that you listed out new schools
would they have to be private because
we're I like you creating a list George
is actually great at this I'm going to
pass this off to you
where she started give her the list that
she would need to make and she begins to
look at different states and different
cities to get to the point where she
goes okay I can check this off this
office off and even now I know
we can make this change and it's not as
painful as possible yeah there's two
lists for you Danny one is the financial
side so let's start to make a fake
budget using every dollar and go here's
what our life could be in this look up
all the cost of living things look at
private school costs and start to
actually look at facts and you may go oh
we're going to be fine we're still gonna
have plenty of money and then look at
housing so if we looked at this kind of
house here's how quickly we could pay
that offer we could pay cash if we did
this and that will give you some peace
on the financial side on the logistics
side start to write down every single
decision you're going to have to make
and it's going to be overwhelming at
first but I promise it's also going to
be cathartic once you get it on paper
and your husband starts to go cool I'll
take that one I'll take that one you
take that one we'll divvy this up let's
come back and do another budget meeting
another meeting to talk about the future
and that's going to give you so much
peace right now there's so many
variables there's so many unknowns
that's just fear